potentially it is the most important
ship on earth it's been a couple of
years in the making on the banks of the
Mersey
but the RRS Sir David Attenborough will
soon head out to help explain our
changing planet the man himself is
honoured but it's the science of our
climate that matters he and everyone
else needs politicians who have focused
on that not fighting each other I fear
that the rest of the world looking at us
can say what are you doing when there
are such huge problems of the facings of
them that you're going arguing on about
this issue
UK significance yes but really there are
bigger problems and this person will
help solve my head it was then the
Duchess of Cambridge who was almost in
sync with the champagne
it is a great tribute but it isn't the
name that the public voted for they
wanted boaty mcboatface but rather than
subvert the will of the people that name
does live on this small yellow sub which
will launch from this vessel is called
boaty mcboatface there has never been a
more important moment for this ship to
get to work and there is no person more
fitting for this beacon of scientific
research to be named after than you
David there are still secrets down in
Antarctica there's ice that's over a
million years old that we've never seen
a bigger ship needs more science and
more possibilities it's not necessarily
the size but it's the state-of-the-art
science equipment on it so we can do new
science we can do more science we can
collect more data and we can go to
places that we could never have gone
before
it's first mission will be next autumn
evidence-based science is the only way
we'll understand what's really happening
Tom Parmenter Sky News Merseyside